[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
she
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on you guys you should be
able to hear me pretty well
should be able to hear me pretty well i
don't know yet give me a second
give me a brief moment
now king uh they don't
know their own game pass man king ain't
playing this
[Music]
let me raise this a little bit
see how that looks oh
there we go i got to figure out
my camera scenario man
i feel like you can improve to me
let's go ahead and and start this man
as you can see i ain't done nothing i
literally just started the game
let me make sure everything looks fine
let me see if
turning off this light will help a
little bit nah
hold up
it's only light in the room
i don't know i have to look into
research because i want
i want to uh stuff look pretty clear
but you know how that goes
let's go ahead and start this
we the last time we played uh we
we got past the first region
unfortunately i died in the second
region
i don't know what's going on in the
second region i don't know if we could
go straight to the second region
i would assume that's not a good idea
because we want to still get the
upgrades from the first region
uh
you died over 10 times i died a few
times yesterday
that scared me that checkpoint scared me
man i don't know why
i'm really not feeling the way
that the melee is
i feel like it should track just a
little bit
play a little bit of a hopscotch moment
there
let's hope for the good guns man let's
hope for the good guns
that's not a good gun but we'll use it
my
oh i can't believe i let that thing
shoot me
that was that was bad on my part
man i don't know why i'm having a hard
time being accurate with this gun
these things are always weak if you
shoot them right after they do that
move
i might go back and get that pistol you
guys i don't know
not particularly filling this weapon
let me go back and get that pistol
this that that weapon is not it
increase speed weapon yeah let's do that
so we can definitely go to the second
map if we wanted to
but i don't think it's let's let's not
do that yet
ah it's like i told you i i got some
notes
that i've made for iop got some notes
i wish you had a primary and secondary
having to get close to that dude it's
kind of annoying
wait for him to shoot one time
get these regens
come on let's go
got him suit malfunction
collect risen and i have to click 300.
oh
see look at that like they they
encourage you to get close to them
but when you get close to them you get
hit
yeah let me get that let me grab that
i'd like to get that that figurine
got these negative effects man
some of the gameplay mechanics is
similar to record but i wouldn't say
like the game
itself is similar to record
i already got too many negative stuff we
ain't doing another one
wow
this ain't really too good of a uh
a run if i say so myself
this is kind of a bad run not gonna lie
i already got negative buffs
wrong way
this game does have a lot of potential
i'll give it that
what kind of online mode would you guys
expect this game to have i'm kind of
curious on that
environmental adaptation isn't unique to
the forest the desert has similarly been
altered
could the whole world be rearranging
itself
see what this is some kind of health
canister
let's go up here and get this stuff
though
ground surge
hmm you think just like a multiplayer
concept in general i don't know if that
would work very well in this
has failed to reveal any symbolism
behind statue wrapping
suffocation imprisonment metamorphosis
i enshroude myself and hide my shadows
look everywhere
and deeper perhaps they were simply
trying to bandage themselves
oh yeah there's no double jump in this
game ascend
i'm about to grab it
we're producing uh i'm not trying to
i ain't trying to to deal with any
nonsense right now to be honest with you
let's stay away
yeah i don't see a multiplayer working
for this game
i gotta do better not to get hit
oh god
got him
man how many are they
there's a lot of them man
oh it's one of them things
we have to get close to it
see look at that like if you insist on
me getting close to it
there should be no me getting damaged
just destroying it
that's the stuff i'll be talking about
with this game
uh
i really could have used that that's
good i needed that
that was a good find there's some sony
trash
it's not bad let's let's cool off the
name
column man it's not like the worst game
you can ever
it's play not the best game either
got to get to the foot of the mountain
wow where's that coming from
some health over here
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh my seat
i can't catch a break with this
with this stuff man i just can't
keep getting killed
keep getting killed well i don't get
killed i just get
damaged by like little stuff like
how did i miss that let's get down here
with the big fella
oh don't pull up on me
hit me fam someone tell me what hit me
what hit me
it's another sarcophagus i have no idea
what these are
all right let's see here there's a
turret right there
let's take our time man this isn't this
isn't a race
oh it's one of them things
let's let's get him away from all these
turrets
look how much health he could say
how
i dispatched the sentient
this must be the severed that wasn't too
bad
is this a switch game no it's not on the
switch i don't know if you're clowning
or you're being sincere but it is not on
the switch
[Music]
come on jeez man
i honestly feel like that if you play
this game at like a close range you're
severely limited to what you could do
i feel like the whole game is designed
to be close range
i mean long range
see like like they want you to get close
to these people but they
they give them these ridiculous
these ridiculous after hits
and they do that on a purpose so you
lose your your combo
this is one of those games that comes
with the console back in the day
you guys are
oh i'm hurt i'm hurt pretty bad man
i don't think i make it out of this
oh great
geez i didn't even see him like the
screen's so dark after time
back to the forest i go
why is sometimes you spawn
here
overview
i didn't drop demon souls hardhead i'm
still playing it
i'm still playing demon souls
got a key
broken calibration
what's this down here
let's scan it
oh my god
wanted to pick that up so obviously i
got hit
gotta collect 200
well the best way to collect 200 is is
to level up
got all these turrets over here
oh my god
i hate these
i things i see one of those green things
oh my god move move move
wow how much damage could you take
uh do you have to get other levels
through tlc
wow
[Music]
you guys are
definitely on that you guys are
definitely on that reek
that uh that return of slander aren't
you
guys got all the jokes in the world
all right we don't have to go through
there again
we'll go back
i'm not gonna lie i am definitely
feeling the repetitiveness of the game
like i definitely am
what happened
oh my god
i guess it froze i assume it froze can
you guys hear me
so you know that's the second time
that's happened to me it happened to me
uh
yesterday morning when i was uh
getting ready for the stream i had to
lock it back up
like you mean to tell me that these
these reviewers didn't have these issues
man i might have to reset my playstation
we are here already i might have to
reset my playstation
how do i even reset this bastard
all right that's for the disc we don't
need that
i mean
can someone tell me how to reset the
playstation do i have to unplug it
where is
hold up
while holding though it i couldn't even
hold the
i couldn't even hold the the power
button like
i had to physically get up and and turn
it off
that's crazy someone go to clip that and
put that on twitter i can almost
guarantee you
how to do all this hard reset stuff just
to play
it again
man recoil really did shut myself down
they shut me all the way down
they were like you ain't playing nothing
so
i cannot believe that happened that was
a little bit more than just a shutdown
guys let's be real here
like that that was a pretty crazy
shutdown
i feel like i'm playing jump rope
playing jump rope
because they shoot the same one over and
over again
ow
gotta be better fam
gotta aim to be better
no
i wonder if i should break this
i'm not going to break it because i just
don't want to have like bunch of
negative things on me man
but i will take this
it's kind of crazy how that happened i'm
not gonna lie
it's crazy how bad the system crashed
i even saw jack move on twitter saying
that he was dropping the game until they
fix the bugs
it's kind of crazy how uh how the
the bugs in the game didn't reflect the
scores very much isn't it
just pointing that out man i'm just
pointing that out
maybe the reviewers didn't have too many
issues i don't know
got some fabricators i don't got i don't
got really anything to do with these
fabricators
yeah there was nothing i could do he hit
oh i didn't get hit
oh i did
ether you gotta love finding ether in
this game
eighth is good oh this is that room
room i still have no clue what it's
about
let's just run over here
ah shock stream actually i'd rather have
that to be honest with you
so
oh
i feel like that hurt i hear something
one of these things
where is he oh he's behind me
oh i don't even know where he came from
oh my god
it wouldn't be so bad if you didn't lose
so much every time you get hit
where is that thing there he is
let's just take care of this dude now
hopefully he's got like a carbon or
something no hollow seeker
we we we don't accept hollow seekers
here
that room kind of messed me up a little
bit i didn't go alive
where is here this
yum yum yum yum
definitely you could definitely needed
this room and i love how they're
disappearing that's some dumb
find a secret room and they start
disappearing
there's a bunch of health things in here
actually
we need the health
all right let's grab no pick me up
i don't think i'll be able to reach it
now
there we go
all right i guess we'll just take this
door here and keep going
this game worth 70 you can find ways to
heal as well
yeah imagine playing this on cocaine
i don't want to imagine that
oh the ball uh five boss which ninety
dollars
i don't know man
oh god
oh god
oh god
thank you
for blessing me with a good weapon
felt like i was playing forever without
a good weapon i'm not ready to leave yet
i want to find the fabricator room
what is this
should i waste my ether on this
do you guys think i should waste my
ether on this i have no
clue what this is i haven't watched
people really stream that much
so maybe someone in the chat has can you
inform me
what this alien doom looking thing is
and is it worth the the ether that it
requires
discovered a device with a sentient
shaped imprint
conducting field tests
but for what purpose
already powered so now i got two lights
you guys say all right
all right and the good thing is is i
could still go and find me
the fabricator room
so let's go find that fabricator room
oh great
i still can find the fabricator room
oh you took a relic from the enemy and
died maybe it
maybe it hurts you and he was already
almost dead
i don't know man i don't know why it
killed you
could have been a glitch
i feel like this game glitches pretty
common right now
oh i didn't even see you
ether
i think this takes you just right back
up
all right let's go over here and see
what this is
kidx iphone transfer sphere
yeah i've already been here
let's run down here get this stuff taken
care of
it's really dark in the woods man
what is yeah here it is here it is this
is what i came here for
this is what i live for
so we got the execution blast
melee kills generate energy blasts
so when i hit someone they blow up the
question is
is hitting someone worth getting that
close to them to generate that ability
i don't think it is that's just me
but maybe you guys feel a different way
then we got the adrenaline stimulant
gain five percent weapon damage
per adrenaline level that sounds pretty
good because
you could have up to a lot i think
that's actually worth it to be honest
with you
if i had enough i'd like to get both of
them but i think i'm gonna i think i'm
gonna go with this
can i have up to 25 percent more damage
that's a lot
i need just a little bit more
a device that in exchange for it seems
to be placed
i spent a lot
[Music]
i just need a little bit more man
i was this place
i felt like i came here one time and it
was relevant now every time i come here
i get annoyed
oh
oh there's two of them
whip it increase
move
whoa
there we go i don't know if i'll be able
to kill him
nope
let's just keep going
there we go
oh
is there any more does anyone else want
to smoke
because i got no problem delivering the
smoke
oh this is one of those rooms that long
let's go in the room that locks
uh
oh my god
blown him up
oh i can't stand these things
come on come on
come on oh my god
i think that means there's two of them
[Music]
where is he
come on
there we go
final hostel is incoming and there's a
lot of them
[Music]
there's like 50 of them
oh
let's go under here
man he's fast
i think that's all the the flying things
come on get your frozen ass
dead
look you don't gotta tell me twice i
know i gotta run
pickup verizon gives you a shield
against the next hit i like that
artifact that's a good artifact
i like some ether too
sure
i feel like having all these weapons is
less relevant
if they make it to where you can only
equip one
like i feel like if there was more than
one weapon you would have like a lot
more scenarios
where you have to actually sit there and
cycle what you want to use
i really feel like there should have
been two weapons like i'm gonna be real
with you guys
i think there should have been two
weapons in this game
i wish i had the grappling hook
this is the house room i'm just going to
use this checkpoint
the fabricated room is just up here
so i might as well just go ahead and go
straight to the fabricator room
i wonder what that transportation thing
would do if i used it
melee grant i don't like the melee thing
builds
i i'd rather yeah let's buy this
pick this up
we don't need that let's go
actually let's go find a teleporter so
we could teleport straight to the door
to the next region
there we go
it's to the right it should be
here we go
how am i liking the game look you guys
obviously i don't know if you've been
here for a while but um
i'm keeping my opinions on the game one
second
i'm keeping my opinions on the game to
myself because i am going
to like go into a full blown on exactly
what i what i feel what i don't feel
about this game
when on iop tomorrow
keep in mind um i don't know if
cognito's posted on twitter but i have
posted it
uh to certain areas that you know we
will be having jeff grub on tomorrow for
iop
so it should be a good show
oh some more turrets
so far this is a good run
so far so good
good run man good run
get rid of that
[Music]
yeah i know i don't i didn't forget
you're there
just gotta get your friends first
i'm starting to learn how to fight these
turrets
you got to be quick with them
are they going to bring in checkpoints
and
uh checkpoints and save points soon to
make it easier for people
i don't know i know a lot of people
don't want them to do that
but to me if it's another mode that has
nothing to do with this mode
then why does it matter to people like
i get it some people want games to be
excruciating but to me
it doesn't matter as long as it doesn't
interfere with your core base
now let me push pause real quick if they
wanted to make
a mode that's unrelated to this mode
that you could go back and forth
to and you don't have to mess with this
mode at all
then why does that matter to people i i
it's like i said i understand
people like to keep hard games like this
at their core
but if a developer wants to give you
additional options
to have more people play the game but
doesn't mess with the original game
why does it matter if they do that
because it's not like putting
checkpoints in this game
is going to prevent them still from
making it hard they're just giving you
another option to play the game
people need to stop gatekeeping so much
man
oh god
watch this not be worth it
looks like i can get straight there
i'm not going for that that's not worth
it
i got a 4.0 right now adrenaline
that's a trap
they tried to get me to slip
oh god it's the one that will jump at
you if you let him
i've see appreciate you stopping by rick
you have a good day playing playstyle i
still haven't played that game
i tried it a little bit but i still
ain't really sat down and played and
played it
oh yo
i like this let's go the lightning one
oh my god i'm happy i'm happy right now
man
i'm happy
it's that's what i'm saying fawns like
to me now
let me let me put a caviar in there
it cannot affect how the core game is
made
but if they want to after the game is
made go through
and put checkpoints and stuff in the
game then i'm okay with that
because i still get the experience i
want and you still get the experience
that you want
oh
come on
what's coming out of that red thing oh
it's one of them things
is it going to go above it or below it
it's going above it
no that's not the big one where's the
big one
oh
feisty
[Music]
oh i got to too cute
no
is it dead yeah it's dead
there it goes with that kamikaze bull
stuff that'd be doing
i doubt there's gonna be any gun that i
want more than this gun
like on the rail
no
i could really use another fabricator
that'd be helpful
whoa
oh my god you scared this
yeah come out here come out here
i got something for you where'd you go
what's this what's that it's a
teleporter thing
i don't know but i'm not testing that
man you might be able to you might not
those turrets just come out of nowhere
man
i gotta be more aware of those turrets
where's another one think it's up here
yep
get this money
oh
all right so this doesn't go all the way
here does it no it doesn't
see what let's go over here and see what
this is
ether always use ether man
turret
something right over there too let's get
rid of this turret though
shocking springs jumps create
energy
there's still something above me
it's probably another turd because he
hasn't moved what was that
you guys seen that it thinks invisible
come on man it's invisible
wow
oh i got the yellow one now
is that water yeah you must get
something in this game to get in water
i don't know what though i think i got
to go back up to the top
ugh
fabricator
increase protection by ten percent i'd
love to have that increased protection
one
but we have to keep it moving
i saw sarcophagus yeah right there
i have no clue what those do
another resin
this is one of those rooms that locked
[Music]
oh turret turret
there's another turret
it doesn't save at all like it only says
when you get like permanent stuff
well i can't say that it probably saves
all the time it's just you don't get
anything
unless it's a certain uh you don't get
anything
whoa i don't know why i went up like
that
oh god it's one of these things again
try to stay away from homeboy until
these are killed
looks like you could stay away from them
pretty easy
what is that
it's one of those things
just keep it moving
oh man
oh god
oh
another ether see what this is
melee kills generate two energy boats
that hit the two nearest targets
it's pretty good i'm not gonna lie it's
it's a good uh
it's a good thing
let's go up a little bit this is a
really good run man it's a really good
run
i gotta get to the other side
it looks like there was something in
there
let's go double check make sure oh yeah
it was a fabricator thing
we don't really need the fabricator
we've already done enough with the
fabric crater and we don't even really
have a whole lot of money to be honest
with you
all right let's go back into that room
and go on the other side
there's a chest up there
looks like another indiana jones room
can i get to it by jumping up
nope
i know why they became severed divine
punishment
for failing ascension ascension
no sooner has the word escaped my lips
than a fast
image of the transcendent water in the
deep below
consumes my mind i have begun having
visions of where i have yet to go
they lead me continually downwards from
olympus and myself
apparently she one of these times she
done this she got crazy
yeah i ain't gonna lie if if it froze
now
i would probably quit
this is like the best round i've had i
would be in my feelings if it froze
just being 100 real with you
i have no clue what these are none
whatsoever but imma get them
oh these block creatures
there's a couple of them oh he's above
me
don't even know what the blue dog blue
doesn't send you in
i'm relatively confident the severed
would have been incapable of sending out
the white shadow broadcast
the fractured nature does not display
any proof of higher
cerebral functions
the other sentience must still be alive
at its source beyond the wall
but without a proper means of
communication will they view me as
hostile as well
i haven't come oh it's another one of
those rooms
another one of these weird rooms
wow
nope
this blue shifting is messing with me
man
i don't know why they did this it's hard
to see
wrapping themselves and the statues
kind of symbolic communication
no you don't have to beat the boss what
happens is you open up a door
to the next area you do have to find the
room for the next area but you don't
have to beat the boss himself
container there's a container up here
somewhere
it's up there
yeah it's right there
i want that container it's calling my
name
give me that container
it's my
nope
what's down here
nothing
all right let's
let's leave this room
confirms authorship of the xenoglyphs
there's one more over to the right
i didn't know you press y on these
fear or worship
these pillars affect the severed soul
how do i get on top of this
oh you gotta have one of those things
all right so it looks like
you don't have to beat the boss again
though no you don't
of the map so far
there's a chest over here
nope
i'm not getting rid of this carving dude
it's not happening
they should just stop asking me
hmm
let's go back to the teleporter
so it's telling me to go here
i just don't know what you do here
so
wait do i have the uh the grappling hook
because i got that one
no i don't
maybe i'm supposed to have the grappling
hook
doesn't look like there's another door
this got to be the way you go
see there's a checkpoint closer
there isn't but we're gonna take this
floor the one over here where is it
it's to the right a little bit yeah it's
right there we're gonna take that one
go this way
oh yeah this line stuff
let's move back a little bit see they'll
come to me
yeah i feel like we're about to get the
um
the grappling hook
feel like we're about to get this
grappling hook
here we go
foreign
gotcha gotcha
i thought i got hit
they need to change what when you level
up or anything they need to change that
color
because sometimes i'll be seeing the red
and i'll be thinking i'm getting hit
the woman who was supposed to step on
the surface of another world
was mom thought she'd be proud of me
where her footsteps may have taken her
if she had the opportunity
is that why i'm here to go where she
couldn't
well fabricate her seeing that house
again
it feels as though she's still judging
me
yeah let's grab that
can never have too many of those
i don't even know where that teleporter
thing takes you
all right let's see here
except for pre-speed and protection yeah
let's do that
i don't even know what that was
no clue what's going on right now
oh god
oh my god i wish it was something better
than that
i don't like that weapon at all
oh there's more
see if i can sneak up behind it going a
different way
what is this
i'm not comfortable going that way
it's one of those big things
no
the only way i take that is if it's
another one of those things
no i want another carbon or it's
nothing man
can i get further up here
oh this one's purple over here
yep we'll take that
we'll take it this
socom i don't know that game just always
looked weird to me
i'm about to jump straight across
this is one of those things i don't need
it right now but it's one of those
things
oh there's two of them
wow
two of them was a lot
all right we'll play that game
yeah how'd you feel about that
what's this another resin
anti-cool it might have to use that
not gonna lie to you guys
i'm still in the second bio
i'm just not for these
yeah it's definitely my best run
i've reached my goal i finally summited
the energy signature is right here
decrease my volume like
i'm right does that sound better hold on
let me load
yeah i mean yeah it does look like a
little bit okay what about is that is
that better
i took creased about like 20 percent
i wish i could find like a little hell
thing
actually there was a health down there
let me go back and grab that i don't
know i might not be able to get back
up there no it doesn't look like it
it looks like if whatever's up here
probably the boss
and if i beat it i'll get that grappling
hook
because there's so many of those
grappling hook things around
whew what is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god
oh he's throwing that down
[Music]
ugh
oh my god
he took so much health from that little
side move that i didn't notice what he
was doing
oh i don't know man i i'm mentally
defeated after that one
like i don't know if i want to go all
the way back through that again
i had such a good run
what's going on well
took him about half his health but man
oh that's that's wonderful
at least i keep the the melee upgrade
oh i didn't even see him there
i appreciate it
are you serious
at least the shield kept me alive
it's always there
so this is a space ninja i would like
say space ninja
oh god
scared me a little bit what's this
broken okay you take that actually
there's something down there
nah i'm not i'm not using that
all i see is a run jump find items loot
i mean that's pretty much the game but i
mean that that's a lot of games to be
honest with you
this is another one of those locked
rooms
oh god
shoot shoot move
[Music]
gotta kill him before the thing comes
out of that door
here it comes
oh yeah let's get the car
on
let's do it
get this ether
two ethers wonderful
get a little bit of health increase
nah i don't i'm not i don't like the
parasites man
i think they're too unpredictable
that's not too bad though because i
usually pick those up pretty fast
whoa
they changing stuff
oh there's a turret
okay oh
i wasn't ready to fight that thing off
uh
what is that oh it's another one of
those things
seventy dollars is a lot of money
especially this being one of the first
ones
i thought i had extra health i think you
guys are lying
to me
getting pretty good drops when it comes
to health
um i already did that star room
uh you know what let's just go ahead and
let's just go back to the desert
i got the gun i like
got a decent amount of health i don't
know
i got a lot of coin man
i got a lot of coin
let me find that fabricator
let me find that fabricator
let me find
do i sound better like am i still like
is my voice still like really really
strong because i'm a decent amount away
from the mic too
this is that room that you can't go any
further until you get that grappling
hook mechanic
what is oh yeah that's the one where you
have to jump open
over
is there another room over here
it doesn't look like it
all right
i gotta find the fabricator room
foreign
it's all that matters but it's just for
my voice not to be crackling or anything
like that i don't i don't want to bust
people's eardrums out
trying to do better man trying to do
better
oh i've never been in this room
uh
there we go was it too bad
i like how they're starting to switch up
what i'm saying
one of these green things
uh
all right i got my
i like the melee i just i wish it felt
more accurate sometimes
sometimes i feel like it's really
unaccurate
i don't think you can get up there
without like a grappling hook of some
sort
yeah you need a grappling hook
where is this fabric here we go now we
in business
i'm gonna take that let me get let me
have that
let's take that
where does this go
like to find some more health
oh god
come on
all right there's that dude
there's that dude starting to get my
adrenaline back too
not trying to get hit
there we go
one more down here oh
all right is there health in here it
doesn't look like there's any health in
here
it's only this little there we go
just money
looks like there is a chest over there
though there's a gun
probably nothing i want no
the chest look cursed so i don't think
we have to worry about that chest
let's go through the blue door
oh it's another one of these rooms
not cleansing it let's cleanse it
so that's what those do okay
i did spend a lot of money cleansing
those but i think it's going to be very
beneficial to be honest with you
no
now we're going to go back to the uh to
the fabricator
what is this
all right let's see here
i've been using the the melee a lot more
here lately so let's grab this
all right let's go unfortunately we'll
just have to go with the health that we
currently have
i'd like to be able to get that health
there but i'm not going to be able to
reach it
looks like there's health
helios is entirely broken and i must
abandon hope for him
initially i thought to merge his systems
with those of the sentients
because maybe these machines would fix
him
who's that who stopped the mines on the
mother ship couldn't
fathom
who is she talking about there
oh yeah this is one of those
let's see
no no
to not lose a consumable on use that's a
pretty good consumable
if i say so myself i would like that
consumable
let's put that
of course i took some damage
that's all right though
yeah i took off the beanie i did
my hair looks a mess but it's okay
it's not even really like i was like
i i had to take it off or anything like
that it's just hot in my room to be
honest with you
i'm gonna go get that teleporter
go back to the crimson waste
is the teleporter in there no
there's a dark chest in there though
i feel like you eventually get something
where you can go in water
i'd like to be able to use this but i
don't have enough
it's just over here
i got everything i feel comfortable
going there now
got a little bit of a grind going on
here
a little bit
oh
internal damage
so every time i pick something up now
i'm gonna take damage
i guess it could be worse
whoa
took a little bit of damage there
some money
money there's a chest there
nothing worthwhile
huh
yeah i don't like that
i don't like that at all how do i get
rid of that
i'm at the final machine and get rid of
these
i definitely wasn't thinking when i
picked that up
it's not like i take a a massive amount
of damage but still
let's go back to the top take 30 minutes
to get back to the top
i wonder what's coming out of that thing
oh
oh it's not playing
go around
come on
no
yeah it's it's a pretty big mob i had to
use my
health because i don't want to risk
dying
i really need to find one of those
machines
what is that
made it to the summit again oh
that's cool all right see they do do
little things to try to make up for the
fact that
you got to do some some crazy stuff
up man what's up
oh they shooting at me
let's try this again
[Music]
so
ugh
uh
man do i dodge into it
no you can't dodge into it
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
damn no i got to tell i got the thing
god
damn i was choking at the end man
ugh i was choking i feel like i could
definitely do that though i could
definitely do that
if i if my weapon would have been a
little bit more upgraded if i would have
got like the shotgun i think a shotgun
would be a good
scenario for that particular fight
it sad i i see the area i know exactly
how to
where to go this is like around the
corner with turrets
and you take this to get back up to the
top where you couldn't go
i don't know where this goes
ah
oh hell no
let's get this money
so
oh
this is probably my last attempt you
guys
i gotta go to work in a couple hours and
i want to relax before i go to work
been watching snowfall too so i wanna
i left off on a pretty crazy part
what is this
oh my god i really don't like the
majority of the guns in this game
where is it
there he is
that was bull
wasn't too bad of a lockdown if you ask
me
let myself get it way too much
what is this
need a fabricator this stupid house i
don't care about this house
there we go
what is that thing
enables a more powerful blade
let's drive that
i only got one i wish i could find a gun
i might have to find one
find some of those rooms
wow
oh god oh god
where is he
[Music]
oh god this gun's like really weak
i feel
come on
yeah i feel like this gun really
underwhelming
maybe it's a little bit more closer
range
i don't know what do you guys think you
think it's too weak
i feel like i was doing way more damage
with the other gun
what's over here
no i don't like that because you it
requires me to keep hold on to the
currency and i'd rather spend it
this is my tenth return
there are four meter tall corpses
littering the ground
piled up perhaps centuries ago
i can't tell if there was civil war
or genocide or mass ritualistic
all right this gun's decent
that's decent it's not bad
stupid red stuff
of course i got shot
please be like a large one no
keep upgrading my armor i want health i
don't want to upgrade it
i mean i could use that large i prefer
that to use that on the boss
oh god
ah
oh much
i hate these things
uh
ether can always use more ether man
come on
oh
yes
yes
let's go
i got so much money
let's go back to the fabricator i feel
like i picked up everything i could pick
up from him
we might have to go to the second
fabricator in the other world
but that requires me to go around and
look for it i don't think i got that
much time
oh god
so
nothing i want
nothing i want
i'd like to have whatever that health is
though
i don't think i can reach it
yeah need the grappling hook
let's just go back to the boss
try to find like a secret area or
something to spend this money
at
the fabricator
there's nothing in that fabricator
really
i don't think it's a good idea to even
go look for that fabricator
what is this
[Music]
hmm
i shouldn't have picked that up but i
did anyway
let's see what it did to me
i'm not going to be picking up much of
anything else so it might
it might work out for me
let's see what the chat is sorry i
haven't been looking at the chat
next time just remember make your way
close it's all pattern and
now i i i low key i choked at that last
one i didn't choke like bad
but it was definitely i could have did
way better
i felt like the last phase
looking it looked like it was going to
be easier than the
the other phase
i'd rather have health
i can break these now right no i can't
there's some health up here
come on
shield vile gives me like one more hit
kind of need that to be honest with you
this is you guys really ain't feeling
this game
please be something i can spend my money
on yes
alright so let's see create a shield on
the next hit
all right let's see here so i got two of
those now
might as well just do another one
so i got two health vials
not too bad
yeah you do have to travel a good amount
but i don't think it's like too too bad
those are kind of useless right now
an ether
okay
oh they're still coming after me
don't want them sticking up behind me
oh god
try to kill him before he gets anyway
close to me at all
god
get all this stuff here
yeah xbox needs a record too i i would
agree
like real i i feel like playing this
game record could have been
so much more and i feel like a sequel
will do it
so much more justice
but microsoft gotta want to do that so
you know
oh man i really want to pick up that
shotgun
i agree i agree
dying over and over again is definitely
something that will upset a lot of
people
man i feel like i picked that shotgun up
it'd be so much better
i'mma keep this though
i got so much money i just want to use
it
oh almost fell off
no i'm not doing that
there we go some more health
is always appreciated
oh god where am i going
it's another one
oh
what's over here
this will help
i'm pretty sure i have a key see what's
over here
huh
find like an artifact or something that
would be awesome i'd like to find a
a suit an artifact suit
so
it might be the oppressive heat but i
keep catching myself glancing over my
shoulder
only to find shadows and the astronauts
staring back
what does that astronaut signify can't
seem to stop this from happening
i want to go straight to the boss i
don't got a whole lot of time left
doesn't look like they're gonna let me
is there any turrets over here
ugh
so
ah
let's see my equipment
all right so i have
there's things over there shooting
please be a good warner carving no it's
not
all right
first off let's throw the shield out
let's get this going
this is the last attempt win or lose
[Applause]
so
oh i lost the shield
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh
that's unfortunate
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
uh
ah
[Music]
oh my god
there's something exalted
found more xenotype technology on
another corpse
scan is again indicating potential for
suit
augmentation
safe to repurpose
so why does this look like a ps4 to me
you guys are
crazy guys coming here all day
slandering this game
we'll perform a function test
test complete apparent function is to
cross
vast distances suit status
remains uncompromised
is it don't am i am supposed to put like
a core or something in that
okay no core
gotcha
yeah it's definitely not a 10 out of 10.
that's for sure
the teleportation gateway in the desert
has taken me into the citadel
beyond the forest's massive wall
white shadow is nearly within reach
scans show that the broadcast originates
from the tower
inside a citadel-like complex
encountered hostile machines fully
automated
i assume this is the third world
yup
wow
oh it's okay i couldn't keep playing
anyway
at least i got the cr i got the hook
shot well not the hook shot but you guys
get what i'm saying
i have to try harder the grappling hook
[Music]
i just want to use it one time
so
uh
that's pretty cool hook shot like a can
i definitely will man i definitely will
i appreciate everyone coming by
uh obviously i got to get ready for work
i i streamed probably 30 minutes longer
than i
originally dissipated on doing but i
appreciate everyone coming by
i don't know when i'll be streaming
again probably monday because
obviously you guys know tomorrow's iop i
don't
i kind of want to do an attic show this
week or uh something
probably on a return so definitely keep
an eye on for that
come to iop tomorrow so we can all
talk to to jeff krobs a great dude from
the industry i can't wait to
podcast with them and until next time
i'm outta here peace